hey guys I'm Ryan Wright tonight I'm
going to be watching the trailer for
house above so below the red band
trailer first trailer for this movie
freaked me the [ __ ] out or movies scare
me that is their intention and it works
does not make me a [ __ ] if I am scared
I'm like a lot of people out there who
keep calling me a queer because I got
scared of the trailer that doesn't make
me gay although there's nothing wrong
with being gay in fact I wish I was gay
sometimes but I got pretty hot
girlfriend now so it's all good sure
some of you guys are staking me talking
about my girlfriend but you know she's
really hot trust me we go above and
below with my she's gonna kill me if I
do sexual things my name is
exactly where someone wants to go what
happened in the black
oh Jesus
oh my
I don't know why I want to watch movies
like this it's always the same
experience I always go into the theater
and I'm like cool this is gonna be an
exciting fun movie the second the movie
starts I immediately regret having done
this journey it's like being on a roller
coaster like you're going up you're
going up and then this second before you
drop your like it looks really scary I
mean the the catacombs you know the the
the cost of phobia that it looks it
freeze like the descent anything with a
claustrophobia just freaks me out buried
I it's mixing like it feels real but
it's supernatural at the same time
that's what looks appealing about it to
me I'm like the reviews for it have been
fairly good so far so because of that
you know it's gonna be creepy [ __ ]
time I'm gonna really because the [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me I grew up Catholic and
because of that anything with hell I
immediately go this is real this is how
it all goes down
my brains is that stupid I don't go oh
this is fiction but I I immediately
believe it is the day when it so is our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ yes so pray
before you watch it it looks scary after
you the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects we're a good channel I
think we have a lot to offer you hang
out with a few guys you have a good time
you have a few built laughs you know
here's some opinions and then if you
disagree with an opinion you'll call me
a [ __ ]
don't know why that's always the go-to
word but that is the go-to word and the
cool thing is I'll be able to watch this
movie with my girlfriend and she's gonna
be jumping all over my bones and I'm
gonna protect her or I'm gonna piss on
her out of fear it's not gonna be in my
pants for summers I'm just gonna whip
out my [ __ ] and piss on her it's it's a
strange thing mine I have to pee on
someone
that's my Jerry doesn't go to the movies
with me anymore so I'm gonna get some
shoutouts here and I want to say this
real fast if you're mainly subscribed
because you want a shout out you might
as well unsubscribe I like the community
a lot but every now and again I noticed
they're people who only subscribe
because they want to shout out and I'm
like the shout out list that we have is
really long so some people have to wait
a while before they actually get it
things get lost so I wanted to say what
you can do is you can message us that
you want to shout out messages through a
YouTube account because that's the least
used thing so it'll be easier to track
it a little avoid people hating me cuz
this is YouTube and YouTube is only
about love there's no hate on YouTube
but you're stupid if you think there's
hate so every time he comes across it's
like well this isn't you I've never seen
this in comment boxes before formally be
patient okay your shoutout it's just
there's people subscribing every day and
there's requests every day so well this
goes on people the list goes on like
Benjamin Cruz kind of hates me right now
muffin man well no one likes muffin man
he's an [ __ ] he's a total dick and
he's subscribed to the channel and he
watches he's one of the food people
watches our videos the most but he's an
[ __ ] he's a [ __ ] douche and he's
little [ __ ] and you mean I'm serious he
says way worse things to myself and
everybody on the channel feel like
soulless you know he keeps asking for a
shout-out and it's like dude you you've
gotten the shoutout I know you have I
like that you guys want shoutouts I do
it's just there's certain behavior that
annoys me as we like the people who come
here for the content and watch our
videos regularly and then you know ask
for a shout-out that's cool but if
that's all that you want and you don't
really care about the videos because you
want to feel good you're wasting
everyone time so if you're gonna get
like impatient and start threatening me
that you'll unsubscribe if you don't get
your shout out soon you can unsubscribe
right now it'll be okay
we'll miss you but you know you check in
every now and again views but shreya
small D you said can this person livin
on the other side of the globe in India
get a shout-out and lose some weight so
are you saying you want to lose some
weight or time you to lose
some way that's that's [ __ ] up I mean
why would you ask for a shout-out what
you want me to celebrate you if you're
telling me to lose weight I have been
working out for your information now
that I am I'm a part of a celebrity
couple yes that's right we're famous
super famous probably the most famous
couple apply she's really in fitness and
so she's getting me in shape man so yeah
I'll use your mean thing you said which
is actually good advice but it sounds
mean to me because I got ego and defense
mechanism problems and use it to fuel me
to lose more weight Joe Taylor now see
Joe Taylor is a subscriber who didn't
ask for a shout-out but you know he's
really [ __ ] cool so I wanted to give
him a shout-out
he actually said no shoutout necessary
here dude just keep doing what you're
doing being off a big awesome guy now
when you say big awesome better you see
them like them that whatever and I wish
you and everyone at the real rejects
well you're all amazing thank you Joe
Joe Taylor you it's people like you I
keep doing this channel that love and
support that care not doesn't knowing
people who are like hey [ __ ] if you
don't give me a shout out of once Greg
watch the subscriber count' just did by
like 10,000 Joe maybe sometime we'll do
some blow and wouldn't you know them
when I bust another flow I'll let these
lyrics go and what didn't you know that
when I think about the schmoes know it's
a good YouTube channel but right now
you're on my channel here we go you
behaving like a distressful damsel
saying you don't need a shout-out it's
unnecessary well guess what man it's
gonna be some hilarity it's gonna be so
[ __ ] funny you want to get shout out
one you know I want to save this one for
last Jovi Fajardo this guy if anyone's
ever earned a shout out it's this
[ __ ] right here if you look at
our channel our channels banner he drew
that whole thing it started off as fan
art and then asked him to draw some
other folks and he drew with all the
rejects and it's [ __ ] awesome man and
here's a picture of it
so Joey Thank You Man thank you listen I
had a girlfriend now but if I talk to
her
surprised to let me suck your dick she
likes the art at first you are kind of
looking like a [ __ ] troll but when
you read your you read you're looking
like a black girl which is better than
control so yeah
but the other ones look great if I can't
you get my girlfriend now she thinks
it's my fault I can't get it up in the
bed cuz I keep thinking of that photo of
her that you drew and Veronica's always
like come on Ryan
let's do it let's have sex just
constantly begging me and I'm always
like I can't because every time I got to
get horny I just get this image of what
Joey Fajardo drew there's nothing wrong
with black girls seriously there's
nothing wrong black girls did you draw a
picture of Veronica naked that would be
cool could you jump picture of Veronica
and I making love I'm pretty sure she
would appreciate